willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung der
letzten sitzung in diesem semester in
der wir uns abschließend mit friedrich
wilhelm joseph schelling beitrag zur
nach kantischen freiheits debatte von
1786 bis 1800 befassen
und er ist deswegen der letzte war ja
auch der jüngste ist und was ist er hat
im alter von 22 jahren also 1797 in der
allgemeinen übersicht der neuesten für
die literatur stellung genommen
zu diesen freiheits streit zu dieser
zeit hatte die in seiner zeit bis ich
ihn fort diese jahreszahl stattgefunden
hatte und die ihn sehr beschäftigt hat
und die vor allem zurückzuführen ist auf
kante position und auf reinholz position
jetzt können wir noch mal kurz
vergegenwärtigen was schelling
geografisch alles erlebt hat als er
studierte theologie am tübinger stift wo
so bekannte denker wie hegel oder auch
dichter wie hölderlin seine kommilitonen
waren also tübingen war zu dieser zeit
theologisch sehr bedeutsam und viele
dieser späteren philosophen hatten
zunächst mal theologie studiert fichte
ist auch ein kandidat
schellings dann sukzessive in jena
würzburg münchen erlangen und berlin
wichtig ist jetzt für unsere zwecke dass
er eben jener rückt weil jena wie wir
schon gesehen hatten
das zentrum dieser nach kantischen
freiheits debatte bildete befasste sich
im laufe seiner karriere mit ganz
unterschiedlichen themen und entwickelte
auch ganz unterschiedliche positionen
die sich teilweise auch korrigiert also
zunächst war der natur philosophisch
interessiert dann entwickelte er eine
identität philosophie identitäts wie du
so viel bedeutet dass schelling versucht
hatte alle gegen
jetzt aufzulösen so birk objekt geist
natur die identität ist das höchste
prinzip das liegt auch irgendwie auf der
hand weil die philosophie jemand den
letzten 1 1 grund suchen möchte von
allem dann behandelte er so nach 1800
das freiheits problem und auch das
problem des bösen beschrieb dann später
eine philosophie der mythologie haben
die offenbarung und seine späte
philosophie also philosophie der
mythologie dafür brauchen die wurde zu
einem anknüpfungspunkt für den kann wie
sören kierkegaard die gegen hege der zur
selben zeit wie schädigen wirkte in ihr
leben zu 1830 starb
hegel und diese extens philosophie tätig
ist möchte sich gegen igel wenden und
die existenz des menschen wieder mehr
ins zentrum
das individuelle das endliche nächstes
jahr das absolute von dem immer
ausgegangen war
soviel zu schellings biografie und jetzt
haben ein paar leitfragen für die
heutige sitzung immer und aber nur 24
bezieht schelling stellung in der
freiheits debatte angesichts der
position von kant und reinhold und
inwiefern unterscheidet schelling
zwischen wille und willkür
wie verhält sich diese unterscheidung zu
der ewigen bekannt jetzt wollen wir noch
einmal zurückblicken und kann's position
kennenlernen vor deren hintergrund
schelling seinen versuch einer synthese
einer vereinheitlichung verschiedener
positionen unternimmt ganz position
lautet dass ein zitat aus der metaphysik
der sitten
die freiheit der willkür kann mich durch
das vermögen der wahl für oder wider das
sittengesetz zu handeln
definiert wie es wohl einige damit es
reinhold gemeint versucht haben
obzwar die willkür als phänomen davon in
der erfahrung
häufige beispiele gibt das ist ein zitat
von kant aus dem jahr 1797 jetzt haben
wir dann auch gegen reinholz positionen
und reinhold hat auf dieses zitat von
kant bezug genommen in einer späten
schrift und hat sowohl sich selbst darin
wieder gefunden und jetzt möchte er sich
rechtfertigen bzw seine position der
willkür bekannt verteidigen ja schon so
wie keine willkür ohne willen so ist
kein menschlicher fehler ohne willkür
denkbar ohne sie würde sich im menschen
nur ein zwar durch re sonnen
theoretische vernunft modifiziertes aber
doch nur bloßes beginnt kein wollen
keine feste selbstbestimmung in
rücksicht auf ein begehren denken lassen
reinhold gegensatz zu können betont die
willkür als entscheidendes definieren
das merkmal der menschlichen freiheit
wären kann wie wir soeben sagen die
willkür nicht als bestimmendes
definitorischen moment in die bestimmung
der freiheit einbeziehen möchte der
grund erkannt ist der dass damit sowas
wie willkürlichkeit im schlechten sinne
und auch empirie zwischen gegebenen
zwecken die wir uns selbst nicht gesetzt
haben das ist der autonomie gedanken vor
aussetzen müssen und das ist
problematisch freiheit hat kann immer
was mit autonomie zu tun also wenn etwas
sich selbst einen vernünftigen apriori
schon unabhängig von der erfahrung
extrem zweck zu geben ein gesetz zu
geben das sieht ein gesetz das
existieren unabhängig von der erfahrung
das ist apriori und diesen gesetzen zu
folgen oder zumindest unter diesem
gesetz zur hand und die willkür ist
dagegen eine art auffassung von feier
die von bereits gegebenen optionen
ausgeht die wir selbst nicht unbedingt
jetzt
autonom hervorgebracht haben man kann
beide positionen gut verstehen und so
tat es auch schelling der jetzt nämlich
versucht beide positionen zu vereinigen
er schreibt jedes bewusstsein real
entgegen gesetzt dh gleichförmiger
handlungen nun ist es was den willen zur
macht und so sehen wir uns durch unsere
philosophie in stand gesetzt den
widerstreit auszugleichen der in den
behauptungen zweier berühmten
philosophen über diesen gegenstand stadt
zu finden scheint zwei berühmten
philosophen sind wie man sich denken
kann und reinhold und er möchte jetzt
den streit über die willkür schlicht
bestimmt die für unten in einer fußnote
die wolke ist zur möglichkeit des
vorstellung unseres freien handels
notwendig gehört also insofern nur zur
erscheinung des willens nicht zu den
willen selbst wer jetzt schon ein
bisschen weiter denkt kann sich keine
ahnung wie jetzt schelling den streit
zwischen reinhold und kant schlichten
möchte also schillings hat die willkür
gehört nicht zum will uns selbst benutze
erscheinung des finanzen aber dazu
notwendig jetzt kommt auf ganz position
zu sprechen stellen kann behauptet in
der kritik der praktischen vernunft der
wille und die praktische das heißt
gesetzgebende 15 1 und dasselbe diese
behauptung wiederholte aufs neue in der
philosophischen rechts wäre der mieter
sich dass reinhold behauptet moralität
und zurechnungsfähigkeit der handlung
lassen sich nur unter der voraussetzung
einer sowohl von der selbsttätigkeit als
von dem streben der begierde
verschiedenen freiheit des willens
denken das ist jetzt also die
ausgangssituation des streits die den
eher schlichten möchte beide als sagt
schelling weiter kann trat heute haben
recht
der willen gibt gesetze nach kant welche
die vernunft ausspricht reinhold wenn
aber der erste der wille ist nichts
anderes als die praktische vernunft
selbst
es ist das natürliche umgekehrtes sagen
die praktisch fünf das gesetz geben uns
ist die rede selbst den einer
praktischen vernunft die uns durch das
gesetz gebietet ist sich jeder
unmittelbar bewusst nicht zur arbeit des
ursprünglichen willens diese stimme nur
durch das medium der von options-
gelangt wenn kant behauptet der wille an
sich ist weder frei noch unfrei als auch
wer gut noch böse reinhold dagegen sagt
der villa als solche können nicht anders
als frei sein
er sei nur insofern willen als er böse
oder gut sein können so ist doch hier
offenbar von zwei ganz verschiedenen
villen die rede
es fragt sich ob nicht das objekt der
videos selbst eine solche doppelte
ansicht möglich macht also hier sehen
wir geht es zu den schlüssel zur
kompatibilität die schelling hier jetzt
vornehmen möchte
wir sehen das objekt das objekt das
heißt er wird selbst der eher macht eine
doppelte ansicht möglich man kann also
sagen schelling will hier so was wie
eine eine gewisse kompatibilitäts
theorie des willens stabilen und der
kann jetzt in eine doppelte ansicht also
man kann sagen die zwei aspekte lehre
des willens kann man jetzt hier
vertreten und das möchte schilling auch
so toll
ja wie wird jetzt schilling weiter
argumentieren wie kann man diesen willen
jetzt in zwei aspekte weiter
differenzieren schellinger hat ein
weiteres zitat eines hat der wille als
solche ist wieder frei nach oben frei
und b dagegen sich auf das gemeine
bewusstsein beruft in welchen willkür
das heißt freiheit zu wählen als ein dem
willen eigentümliches von irgendwo kommt
so redet jener offenbar von fehlern
insofern er gar nicht objekt des
bewusstseins ist dieser vom willen
insofern er im bewusstsein vor jeder
erheben sich über den standpunkt des
gemeinen bewusstseins ja so kann dieser
also reinhold bleibt darauf stehen
jena hat den vorteil voraus dass er
diese selbst aus prinzipien beweisen
kann der wählen sofern er erscheint das
heißt zum standpunkt des bewusstseins
ausgesehen müsse als freiwilliger
erscheinen
obgleich dieses vermögen absoluten
willen der leyen gesetz geben ist gar
nicht ge denkbar sei die asse bleibt
nicht übrig als sich auf das urteil des
gemeinen praktischen verstandes prüfen
dass er selbst nicht weiter erklären
kann wie es aber zu gehen dass jeder
kann ein so großer philosoph etwas
behauptet dass den gemeinen bewusstsein
sind sprechen scheinen weiß er nicht
begreiflich zu machen und kann sich
deshalb bei seiner eigenen widerlegung
jener ihm sowie technischen beratung
nicht beruhigen
also hand sagt schilling
erhebt sich über das gemeine bewusstsein
was ist jetzt das gemeine bewusstsein
das gemeine bewusstsein ist eben das
bewusstsein zu wählen wählen zu können
zwischen gleichermaßen möglichen
optionen die einem präsentiert werden
das ist das in meinem bewusstsein aber
das bewusstsein der wilken ich kann
wählen ich habe optional kann hingegen
will
etwas wie den absoluten den vielen
denken sagt jetzt schelling und zwar aus
prinzipien also nicht empirisch gegebene
optionen sind da der ausgangspunkt für
kant nach schilling sondern prinzipien
also ab rio rische gedanken von denen er
ausgeht um den willen und die freiheit
zu bestimmen
ja das ist jetzt schellings re
formulieren dieses bekannten streits und
jetzt schauen wir mal realistin versucht
aufzulösen gewinnerinnen erscheint muss
notwendig erscheinen dies und nicht mehr
kann beweist wieder einmal und gerade
eben dies behauptet auch nun ist es aber
der charakter des endlichen geistes dass
er ins unendliche vor sich selbst
erscheinen
sein eigenes objekt sei für sich selbst
empirisch werde diese nun möglichkeiten
sein eigenes objekt zu werden ist das
einzige was gleichsam zwischen uns und
die unmöglichkeit tritt was also ich
jenseits dieser notwendigkeit liegt das
haben wir mit dem unendlichen selbst
gemeint das liegt für uns insofern
tierisch sind in der unendlichkeit
nun ist es aber unser wille eine tat die
an sich selbst gar nicht dem pier
schließt dies behaupten beide haben
alter liegt unser wille für uns in die
unendlichkeit entflieht jeder
empirischen erklärung das wollen kann
ins unendliche fort nur aus dem vollen
erklärt wird also schädigen versucht
jetzt den streit zwischen kant und
reinhold so aufzulösen dass er den viele
als willkür fast als den willen der
erscheint das ist hier
der wieder als willkür und der wille der
erscheinen kann der aber nicht erscheint
sondern von den tv die erscheinung ist
das ist der wille den schilling bei kant
zu erkennen kann
also sind diese zwei aspekte die den
wind nach stellingen ausmachen
und jetzt möchte ich zum schluss noch
eine dienstleistung anbieten und zwar
mache ich oben rechts einen link zu
einem anderen video von mir wo ich
ausführlich dargestellt habe wie man
philosophisch ausarbeiten schreibt also
wie man ein eigenes thema findet wie man
es eingrenzt wie man eine gliederung
entwickelt wie man ein gedankengang
strukturiert schauen sie mal da rein
ich glaube das könnte ihm jetzt helfen
ist die abfassung ihrer anstehenden
hausarbeiten und ich hatte noch ein
video produziert da gehe ich auf die
technischen aspekte ein
oben rechts ist es und da wir endlich
die fragen wie man aus arbeiten nicht
nur philosophischen auch sagen wir mal
geisteswissenschaftlich aus arbeiten
korrekt formatiert und zwar mit hilfe
von microsoft word nur als beispiel wie
stelle ich bin ein richtiges gutes
inhaltsverzeichnis wie wähle ich denn
zeilenabstand habe ich immer wieder
anfragen kommen schauen sie oben rechts
ein
das könnte ihn auch helfen und jetzt
wünsche ich ihnen zum schluss alles gute
eine produktive und erholsame
vorlesungsfreie zeit